hi today we are going to work on
probably the most basic movement that
there isn't done which is the change of
weight now when we talk about change of
weight we are not talking only about
these about changing your weight from
one foot to another in zero position
this is just the most basic but you
could for example have your legs crossed
when you change the weight like this
this is something that happens often in
several figures in town you can of
course have the other leg in front when
you change your weight you will also
change the foot that is in front in
every change of weight like this this is
sometimes called change of length can be
Latinas in Spanish you could also change
the foot that is behind in every change
of weight like this yeah so we have seen
now four different kinds of change of
weight that we can use what we are going
to do today is first we will start with
our warmup like usual then we will do
different exercises for each one of
these changes of weight with a metronome
and then as is usual in this class we
will combine peoples of 90 degrees to
both sides with the changes of weight to
make the exercises more interesting and
more useful the point of the class is to
show you a wide variety of different
types of changes of weight in different
contexts that depend using your dance
and even if you don't use all of the
we are going to see today at least they
can inspire they can give you ideas that
you can try later when you got stuff
okay so let's start with okay let's in
the warm-up it's the same one as every
class we will change it from time to
time in the next classes but this is a
very very good warm-up for tunnel
because it works out all the parts of
your body and it leaves you ready for
dancing so we start the feet together
and then we start with shoulder
rotations as always use only the
shoulders I'm going to use their looks
okay and we will do it so let's start
slowly one two three four five six seven
and eight
now we will do circles with the arms
remember we start the down then we go
forward then we go up remember to
stretch their loops and keep the
shoulders down and then open their arms
to the sides at this point we open the
chest and then down and then we start
again very slowly okay we do six seven
[Music]
eight
this will be great for your embrace
later
you chest forward and relaxed shoulders
which is always good now we do our
stretch for the sides of the torso so we
put one arm up and then we slide down
our leg with a hand until we can touch
our name or organs so we keep this
stretch for three seconds and then we
use the handle is up to pull ourselves
to the vertical again and then we drop
the arm and we repeat to the other side
so we do 4 to each side I start with the
right up down to the leg hold it 1 2 3
now to the other side arm up slide on
your leg hold it
1 2 3 and then pull yourself up and then
drop the arm to up slide down your leg
on the stretch to up slide down your arm
3 arm up Schneider that's the knee hold
it
drop down three up slide down your leg
touch the knee hold the stretch the last
one slide on your me hold it and the
last one to decide down the knee hold it
then we open our legs more or less the
same width as our shoulders we bend the
knees we keep the hip on the head
looking forward we make a circle with
the arms in front of us and we do
rotations for the torso with sixteen to
each side one two three four five six
one two three four five six seven eight
now we stretch the legs and we profile
so you can see and then we are going to
bend on the hip and stretch the lower
leg so first we put our hands behind our
head like this then we bend down until
our back is parallel to the floor then
we keep going down until we hand down
from our hip we bounce three times one
two three and then we recover the
parallel back to the floor and then we
go up and we do it intact okay so let's
go one parallel to the floor bounce
bounce up to Parnell to the floor
bounce bounce bounce parlance offshore
and three-parter to the floor bounce
bounce up for our to the floor bounce
bounce bounce
five five men to the floor
bounce bounce bounce parallel to the
floor up six para the floor
bounce bounce bounce up seven partner to
the floor vomits vomits vomits and the
last one eight the floor bounce bounce
bounce
pardon the floor the next one we keep
the legs open and the knees straight
heels on the floor we grab our hips we
go back we go side with the hip at this
point you feel a stretch on the inside
of the leg then we go forward we go to
the other side you should feel the
stretch on the inside of the other leg
and then we go back we keep the hip more
or less in the same place on time it's
only the hip moving okay and we do eight
circles to one direction
school direction so let's go one two
three
make a big circle for keeps legs
stretched five six seven eight and now
to the other side one two three four
five six seven eight okay and the last
one is to strengthen our lower leg and
our foot our feet so we start bouncing
three times or with the knees bent
bounce bounce bounce and stretch the
knees and then we push the floor down so
we go on the toes and we hold this
position for three seconds okay mmm
be careful that your legs don't open
like this this is dangerous
try to keep your feet really straight on
your ankles together okay so let's do it
eight times we go down on the knees
bounce bounce bounce
strengthening who are 43 seconds one two
three - bounce bounce bounce stretch
hold it one
three bounce bounce bounce stretch go up
hold it
one two three four
bounce bounce monsters legs go up
hold it one two five bounce bounce
bounce go up two three six bounce bounce
bounce
stretch block hold one two three seven
bounce bounce bounce stretch one two
three and the last one eight bounce
bounce bounce there's legs go up hold it
one two three
okay we're done let's go for the first
exercise of changing weight so first
exercise for changing weight without
feet to the other in zero position the
most basic one now before we start I
would like to define a few terms musical
terms so that we are on the same page
for each exercise and you understand
quickly how each exercise works so as
usual I have said my metronome to two
beats per guard and I think 158 BPM
quite slow now the first beat of the bar
usually is called the down
because when you market usually you move
your hand down like this but yeah the
second bit is called the puppet because
when you market you move your hand up so
when you make the beat will be gum it up
it down it up it down yeah
when we count the repetitions for our
exercises for example we can change the
weight we are always going to count only
the downbeat yeah and they're happy
we're going to count it as so we will
companies and so on so when we see a
number is always the down treat when we
said when we counted athlete is always
on okay now for the change of weight the
technique is as follows it's a very
basic movement but I recommend you to
pay attention to the details for example
that when you put your foot on the floor
you make sure that your toes are relaxed
and open separated and extended forward
that you don't bend the baby's yeah open
the whole foot open the doors and put
your foot on the floor as flat as
possible try to distribute the weight of
your body equally through the whole
surface of your foot heel ball toes
everything is flat on the floor and then
you put your weight completely on top of
the food and the free food you can lift
a little bit a few millimeters almost
nothing in order to make it free yeah
don't keep it on the floor
and then make sure that the food is open
put it flat on the floor and shift your
weight to the other foot that's the
technique now another thing for the
timing of your movement cry when you
change your way to not step on the floor
too early we all step too early when we
dance when we practice we have a
tendency to step a little bit too soon
we want to do the movement it's
happening sooner than it should so try
to be as precise as possible when you
put the foot on the floor is exactly the
moment that you hear the we in America
and if you can be even a little bit late
you should not be out of time but you
should put the foot on the floor as late
as you can use as much time as possible
between changes of ways this will
improve a lot of how your autonomous
looks in the dance floor on your
received musicality okay so let's start
to sit together and now we are going to
step on the downbeat with the right foot
so this would be one connect this would
be yeah I'm going to doing 16 cups so
make sure that your cursor is right then
your arms are go put your weight on the
left
[Music]
now we stop we step on the okay let's go
to the next one okay now we practice
cross changes of wait so we are going to
cross the left foot in front of the
right foot
keep your feet together parallel be
careful with ease don't have the lead
feet looking at each other like this and
make sure that one knee is in front of
the other knee don't have both knees
visible from the front the back knee has
to be behind the front knee so your legs
make like an X okay and we will use the
metronome and we are going to step on
the downbeat with the food that is in
front okay we will do it sixteen times
that is very slowly and then we will
change
plus the right foot in front and we will
do it 16 times more okay
feet together
cross the left foot in front of the
right feet together and partner 1 in
front of the other straight posture and
they step on the downbeat with the front
foot 16 times
[Music]
okay now change your feet cross the
right foot in front of the left foot
feet parallel close to each other one be
in front of the other straight posture
and we step on the down okay make sure
that every time you change the way your
feet are completely flat on the floor
then you don't have more weight when the
okay now let's go to the next exercise
okay now we are going to exercise
changes of leg so in each change of
weight we are going to change the foot
that is in front so in each change of
weight
we have to move our free foot from
behind to the front okay and as before
when you step when you change the way
try to have your feet close to each
other together and not like this and
also try to step really next to your
standing food with the free food so that
you don't keep going forward every time
you change the way that means trying to
stay on one place okay and the last
thing is when you are moving the free
food trying to make a very tight and
small circle around your standing foot
don't do a big circle like this because
now we are working with slow tempo but
later if you try this with faster tempo
and you make a big movement you just
won't have time for that so I recommend
to always make a very small circle with
free food and to keep the foot on the
floor
also don't miss the food like this the
food because this also takes too much
time keep it on the floor and keep the
movement compact and small okay so we
are going to do it twice first we are
going to step with the left foot on
every downbeat so it's going to be one
two three left foot goes forward
sixteen times and then we will do it we
will stay
with the right foot confront every time
we share down with so it's going to be
one - yeah it's basically the same woman
but we change which foot steps on the
downbeat way so let's start with the
first one put your feet together make
sure that your coaster is straight arms
in that membranes keep your arm slow put
your weight on the right foot and now
we're going to step on the downbeat with
the left in front okay
six seven eight okay now we're going to
step with the right foot in front on a
great downbeat
so put your weight on the left foot six
seven eight okay now let's go to the
next exercise
okay now we are going to
practice change of leg by changing which
foot is behind in each change of weight
like this so it's going to be the
opposite of what we did before instead
of moving there are three food forward
you know we're going to move our three
foot back okay we'll do it twice again
and on the first time we are going to
step on the downbeat with the left foot
so it's going to be one one two five
three and then we will do it sixteen
times more by putting the right foot
behind on the downbeat so it's going to
be one two three and so on
it's the same movement but we change
which foot steps on the downbeat in each
time and remember the technical things
yeah keep your feet together and move
your free foot as close as possible to
the standing foot don't do a big circle
because with faster tempos you won't
have time to the left
don't leave the food don't do this when
you change weight because you also don't
have time for this when you do it fast
and also when you step put the free food
as close as possible to the standing
foot both feet are parallel you know be
careful with this tunnel and try that
you are not going back in each change of
weight yeah so you have to as much as
you can stay on one place all the time
while you
okay so let's make them again now
remember we're going to step with the
left foot behind on the downbeat so put
your feet together make sure that your
posture straight the arms have low and
down membranes put your weight on the
right foot and we start with the left
foot okay five six seven eight okay now
we're going to step on the downbeat with
the right behind ya so feet together I'm
sixteen times six seven eight anymore
one two three four five six seven and
eight not okay good so with this
exercise we have finished the four kinds
of change the way that we're having done
go in one direction only now in the next
book we are going to have pivots to each
one of these
sizes to make them more interesting or
more useful so let's go to the next book
okay so now we're going to repeat the
first change of way we'll fit to the M
zero position changing from one foot to
another one and two but we are going to
put a 90-degree spirit after each down
move it so it's going to look at each
one T 1 2 P 3 P 2 O 5 4 3 1 ok so for
the people the technical deep side bend
your knees
keep your legs together and start the
movement from the torso and then
following the shape and then change the
weight yeah so we're going to do it
16 times we're going to step on the
downbeat with the right foot and we're
going to make the pivot towards the
standing leg so clockwise ok straight
posture
put your weight on the left and we start
with the right to be with 3 p4 p5 p6 p7
p8 more 1 p1 to p3 p4 p5 p6 p7 fever Hey
okay now we're mentally together
we will stop step on the downbeat with
the left and we're going to put the
pivot towards the stomach just like
right now so on the left
[Music]
five six seven okay now we're going to
do it to the other side we step on the
downbeat with left and we make
okay put your hey hey okay great let's
go to the next exercise
okay now we are going to put the pillows
on the clothes changing weight so for
the first one we are going to put the
left foot in front of the right we're
going to cross the left foot in front of
the right foot we are always going to
step on the downbeat with the front foot
so it's going to be one and two and we
are going to put a 90-degree P words
after the downbeat in this case the
pivot will be away from the standing leg
so clockwise so it's going to look like
this one P 1 2 P 3 P 4 P 5 ok and then
we will go into the other side and then
we will change the directions of the
pivots so let's do the first one
together so we're ready feet together
straight posture tongue embrace and now
cross the left foot in front of the
right
keep your weight on the back foot
because we are going to start with a 1
okay
[Music]
p5 p6 p7 p8 be okay
now isn't it to the other side let's put
the right foot in front of the left
let's step on the downbeat with the
front foot and after the downbeat
we put a pivot of 90 degrees away from
the standing leg so in this case
counterclockwise 16 times okay anymore
1 2 3 4 5 6 7
b.a.p ok could you have balanced
programs
Bendis this will also make it easier to
cut one link behind the other if your
legs are flexed okay so now let's repeat
the whole sequence by changing the night
we step on the on the going to be okay
okay okay okay so with four feet by six
feet
great people okay
great let's go to the next book okay now
we are going to combine peanuts with
change of leg front where we change
which foot is in front on each change of
weight like this okay
so how it works is ladies for the first
exercise on the downbeat on the one we
are going to cross the left foot in
front of the right then after this we're
going to do a pivot of 90 degrees
towards the standing leg so in this case
counterclockwise and then on the end
we're going to cross the right foot in
front of the left and then we are going
to repeat so it's going to look like
this one left foot in front pivot of 90
degrees counterclockwise and right foot
in front repeat - let's put in front
people 90 degrees counterclockwise and
right foot in front three left foot in
front pivot 90 degrees counterclockwise
right foot in front of them and left
foot in front for people and right foot
in front okay
so let's do it sixteen times with the
metronome all together okay so get ready
sit together straight posture comes in
tongue embrace keep the arms low and the
shoulder
relax and put your weight on the right
foot because I'm the one we're going to
start with the left foot
okay so let's go 1 p12 p13
people time for 3 or 5 people 5 6 7
fever I hate people I ate more one p3 p4
p5 p6 p7 p8 people time ok now let's do
it to the other side so on the downbeat
we're going to cross the right foot in
front of the left
then we are going to do a pivot towards
the standing leg so in this flight case
is going to be clockwise and then under
and we are going to cross the right foot
the sorry left foot in front of the
right yeah so it's going to be like this
one foot in front right foot in front
for okay so this with 16 times with a
metal feet together and put your weight
on the left because on the one we're
going to cross the right one two three
four five five one six seven field and
hay fever and eight more one time for
fever high fever time six seven eight
okay good now we are going to repeat
these two exercises but we are going to
change the direction of the pivot yeah
so for example for the next one on the
downbeat we are going to cross again the
left foot in front of the rod but then
the people is not going to be drawn as a
standing leg is going to be away from
so in this case clock works under the
Alec rather to cross the right foot in
front of the left yeah
so it's going to look like this so it
one down with left foot in front pivot
clockwise and right foot in front to
left foot in front pivot clockwise right
foot in front see let's do it in front
pivot clockwise and right foot in front
and four left foot in front peoples
clockwise right foot in front okay good
so let's do this 16 grams with a metal
seat together and put your weight on the
right foot because I'm the one who start
with it okay so let's do it together for
p1 five six seven eight any more koop
three people four people five people
five six field time seven people huh Hey
okay for the last exercise of this cook
we're going to do this to the other side
so which means that on the downbeat
we're going to cross the right foot in
front of the left and then the people is
not going to be tourists family
it's one of the buttons is going to be
away from standing lengths of counter
clockwise 90 degrees and then on the
earth we're going across the left foot
in front of the rack and then we repeat
so it's going to look like one right
foot in front people counter clockwise
and left foot in front to right foot in
front people counter clockwise around
left foot in front three right foot in
front people counter clockwise left foot
in front for right foot in front people
to counter clockwise left foot in front
okay good so let's do it 16 times with a
metronome feet together and put your
weight on the left foot because I'm the
one who started with right okay three
four five six seven eight four one two
three zero four people are 5 P 6 P 7 P 8
people hunt ok so that was the block
with P words for a change of weight to
the front now let's do it to the back in
the next section okay this last block we
are going to combine pivots with change
of leg back so when we change which foot
is behind in each change of weight okay
this one so how it works is like
the first exercise on the downbeat on
the one we are going to close the right
foot behind the left okay and then we
are going to do mentally spirit towards
the standing leg which is the body so in
this case is clockwise okay and then on
the end we are going to close the left
foot behind the right and then we're
going to repeat okay so it's going to
look like one right behind left pivot
clockwise left behind right - right
behind left pivot clockwise and left
behind right three right behind left
peanut clockwise left behind right for
right behind left pivot clockwise right
and left behind right okay so let's wait
16 times with the feet together and then
put your weight on the left foot because
I'm the one we're going to start with
the right back okay - p3 p4 p5 p6 p7
feel and they feel and anymore
1b what I do feel three core people
guys see what I see Stephen and seven
people and people okay now it's a lift
to the other side so on the downbeat on
the one we're going to cross
the left will be on the right and then
we are going to do a 90 degrees view
towards the standing leg which is the
battery so in this case is going to be
plenty degrees counter clockwise okay
and then on the end we are going to
cross the right foot behind left so it's
going to look at is one left behind
right be what
counterclockwise and right behind to the
left behind right people counter
clockwise right behind left three left
behind right people counter clockwise
right behind that 4 left behind right
people counter clockwise and right
behind it okay good
so let's do it together 16 times with
the maximum prepare your feet and then
put your weight on the left foot
okay p5 p6 p7 p8 more one people time gu
v 3p 4p high fever time 6 P 7 P 8 P 1
okay good now let's repeat these two x's
we're changing the direction of the deal
instead of towards standing it will be
what our way from the standing so for
the next exercise on the downbeat we are
going to cross again the right foot
behind the left on the one and then
we're going to do a 90 degrees people
not towards the standing leg which is
the back leg we're going to do it away
from the standing leg so in this case is
going to be counterclockwise and then on
the earth we're going to cross the left
foot behind the right yeah so it's going
to look like each scrap one right behind
left people counterclockwise and then
left behind right - right behind left
people counterclockwise and left behind
right three right behind left people
counterclockwise and then left behind
right for right behind let people
counterclockwise and then left and right
okay so let's do it sixteen times with a
metronome fit together and put your
weight on the left foot because four
five six seven eight one good deal 3b
one core p5 p6 p7 p8 okay now this is
this one to the other side so on the
downbeat
we're going to plus the left would be in
the right and then the people is not
going to be towards it standing it so
it's going to be away from the standing
leg so in these states
it's clockwise okay and then on the end
we're going to cross the right foot
behind the left and then we're going to
repeat so it's going to look at one left
behind racket people clockwise and right
behind the left to left behind right
people clockwise and right behind this
three left behind right people clockwise
and right behind left forward left
behind right field clockwise and right
behind them
okay so absolute together sixteen times
with a metronome fit together and then
put your weight on the right because
we'll start with okay time 3 P 4 P 5 P 6
P 7 P 1 P 2 P 3 P 1 and core p5 b 1 and
6 P 7 P 1 and any field and ok good
so this was the last book it was a bit
complicated at the end but you can watch
this last section and as many
until you understand the logic but it's
really simple you have to close in front
yeah
or you have to close behind in each
exercise you just change which foot
crosses in front or which foot crosses
behind and then you change the direction
of the pivot one time you do it on one
side the other time you do it on the
other side and that gives you all these
four combinations of steps that you can
do and this will improve a lot your
coordination with the legs and your
possibilities when you dance in in the
younger on drive combinations and for
all the exercises that we I recommend
you to make really compact movements
yeah so for example when you are
changing the feet try to move the leg as
close as possible to the standing leg
yeah like what we did without the pivots
or with the pivots yeah this move your
legs really contact okay so I hope you
have fun try these exercises with
different temples try faster every time
a little bit more and then I hope that
this will help you thank you very much
see you in the next video bye